ivamektin is best known for treating
parasites in livestock
and in human form as a treatment for
skin conditions like scabies it's been
taken
safely by billions of people
trials conducted across the developing
world have also revealed ivermectin to
be an effective treatment for covet 19
reducing symptoms cutting mortality by
up to 75 percent
and even inhibiting transmission
in parts of india it's been credited
with bringing covert 19 infections down
to manageable levels
while authorities in uttar pradesh have
announced they'll provide a protective
dose to every devotee attending the
magmela festival
on the banks of the ganges river next
year for countries like us it is a
wonder drug because it has a long
history of use
in asia and africa many of the countries
where obviously
apart from they cannot be at home for a
long time they have to go for work and
they have to cure themselves
and this is a very cheap drug an
affordable drug which is
less than two dollars or the full course
a group of doctors in the united states
collating data from studies like dr
khan's in bangladesh
now believe ivamekton should be put to
immediate global use
it works not only at prevention early
treatment but it even works late phase
in the hospital even patients on
ventilators
have shown improvement when they get
ever met in and at that point it's not
the virus replicating it's
all severe inflammation and so what i
say and i what i've said to colleagues
and what we believe in my group
is that if you were going to design a
drug for all the phases
and and the the patho physiology of
covid
ivermectin would be of the drug the
wealth of data that exists on ivermectin
hasn't yet
encouraged many rich world medical
regulators to act
in part because the focus here has been
so squarely
on vaccine development and in part
because of an apparent reluctance
to accept low-budget developing world
data
but as the virus mutates into more
lethal strains and as
concerns grow that vaccines alone may
not be the long-term answer
so interest is building in iva mektin
with its potential
to be both prevention and cure
so much so that researchers at oxford
university are conducting a trial of
their own
although we're hopeful that vaccines are
going to do what's promised
the data is not very reassuring that
they're actually going to achieve
everything that they're setting out to
achieve but uh if they don't
we'll have another tool as as a backup
and is one that we can deploy now
while waiting for the vaccines right
there there's huge portions of the world
which don't have anything available to
protect them or to treat them
after intense lobbying by healthcare
professionals slovakia this week became
the first eu country to approve the use
of ivamectin as a treatment
for covid19 wider use
may not be far behind jonah hull al
jazeera